so you get a lot of these emails I mean
I mean I'm sure you get a lot of emails
from people just about their scripts and
all that that whatever just a consultant
but I'm I'm curious on how much
correspondence you'd get from people who
were struggling with challenges beyond
just the challenge of writing like this
not not too many I think that they're
more memorable because they're painful
to me because if people are emailing me
saying I don't know how to get an agent
it's sort of like the director of course
the cab there's there is a solution to
that that probably will work there is a
process but when you're when you're
trying to help somebody who is up
against a real emotional crisis and
facing people who really aren't
supportive it's hard to say take these
three steps and it'll all be taken care
of so I think they're more memorable
than they are a frequent but it's tough
to do I would add to this maybe but it
occurs to me that there's another kind
of email I seem to have gotten a lot
lately and that is the person that
emails and says I'd like you to look at
my script I don't want you to coach me I
don't want any consultation all I want
you to do is read it and send me back
one sentence saying am I wasting my time
or not and my answer is I haven't
composed the answer I think I'm going to
put it on my next blog but it's always
some form of I won't do that I it's not
my place to decide if you're wasting
your time there's only one person that
can answer that and that's you because
to me whatever it is in this if you're
directing if you're acting if you're
writing if you're an accountant if
you're passionate about it are you
getting joy from the process of doing
that it doesn't mean every day as a
smile on your face but it means overall
this is what makes me alive then you
should be doing it and if you're not and
you're doing those creative things for
any other reason than me and then the
joy it gives you like money or success
or rebellion or whatever then you
shouldn't be doing it but it has nothing
to do with talent and success - right or
the quality of that one script no no
yeah absolutely not
I mean I I don't I won't even make that
evaluation about a script I I would
never say this script sucks or this
script is great my job is to say this is
what you've done or or you've done this
my job is to help you make it better and
I help writers that make million dollars
a script make them better and I help
brand new writers make them better
that's all I'm there to do anything else
is their decision about how they want to
spend their time
you